that's not the plan yeah real 92.3
bootleg cab here James is here come on
now
how you feeling man hey man I'm just
excited because we got in my opinion
I think you might be the uh well first
of all you're the greatest of all time
when it comes to this hip-hop journalism
thank you sir but I also would like to
point out that I truly believe that in
the last
seven or eight years you have the best
you and bdot have the best interviews at
like period I appreciate when you guys
drop it matters bro thank you brother
like I know y'all ain't doing like the
hype but when y'all drop it matters
absolutely I feel there's pressure on us
now with these interviews man it's
almost like we do a great interview it's
like oh another great interview it's
just like yo that's not easy like you
know what I'm saying like like the Tyler
we're very proud of right but you know
that doesn't mean that Jay-Z wasn't
great or Drake wasn't great or Will
Smith or nipsy hustle like but you know
now we feel that pressure to kind of
have that quality interview that kind of
adds to that it kind of I feel like the
interviews you guys are doing are like
helping kind of add to the legacy of a
lot of these guys yeah and building the
catalog because I think so much of our
thing I think you do that obviously
which what you do it's like you want to
build a catalog you want something that
still has value you don't want the
cookie cutter [__] you want we want to
create great content that people can go
back years later and still draw from
them and like you know how it is not
when these kids rip your [__] and put it
in reels and right the problem my [__]
pops up I'm like that's one of mine like
yeah and I'll put the uh the hashtag in
it because kids don't they'll do it
quick they'll do the crazy Zoom when you
don't even see me and [__] like what's
up hey I'll throw my hashtag down there
yeah that was me the Tyler I said the
Tyler interviews first of all interview
of the Year thank you brother
um and I don't know I feel like the the
I saw this complex list that came out
that I I wasn't on but I feel like it's
crazy it should have been on that list
that's what we said obviously
I mean
I mean be top three I mean you listen
this year alone we got Jay-Z yep
the best interview so far this year in
hip-hop
um and I think look homeboy switched the
style up he went bad again young boy but
that's the biggest interview that's
actually point two million I think the
NBA youngboy interview because he's back
on his [__] yeah but I do think that
that was one of the more like if we
think about the last 10 years numbers
wise yeah you guys got to speak to him
in a way that nobody else really has
absolutely absolutely and I was crazy I
saw people like you know he's still
under the house arrest we could only
have like three people in the house at
one time so it's literally like finally
permission for me and beat out in the
camera guy to come in and we walk in and
he's like behind the door he's like how
you gentlemen doing I was like
so you walk in there this is in Utah
right yeah yeah this is like the
snowiest Jack Nicholson shining type
thing going on um and then we sat down
it was cap was like awkward silence and
then you know we got two and you hear it
you kind of hear how awkward it is in
the beginning
and it's that's really what happened and
then the camera guy had left and then
the photographer Kenya she came in and
sips no no more the three people could
be in the house for the federal rules of
the law in this house at one time in
that area to do the interview so we had
to right we had to be on point I was
gonna say for you guys like I I mean
obviously young boy is like I always say
it ain't for me you know what I mean
yeah but it's for a lot of people my
nephew's one of them Hunter yeah 100
right I'll find a couple drugs for him
but I can't say I was the biggest one
like we were it's almost like but we
were like yo but dude I want to
understand him more and I think he's
very conflicted I think that you see a
side of who he is in our interview and
then you see his other side and I think
he's trying to not you know he knows the
dangers of going that way but I think
that if he gets angered he goes that way
so I think it gives more insight to who
these people really are like who these
artists are so that was what the
challenge was there he wasn't coming in
there like we're the biggest NBA young
boy fans we have to document how Dopey
is it was more like this is the this is
a crazy story about one of the most
impactful influential young artists in
the game doesn't get his respect and the
numbers deserve him being in those
conversations yeah for sure
but the fans don't I was gonna say um
you've had so many errors uh we can go
back to Ego trip to the YN era at double
XL I'll give you the exclusive I think
we're uh we're working on some type of
ego trip book to sort of like I have the
book of rapless at my house no no the
book of all the magazines we did oh okay
let's go team magazines we did uh like
collectors of them have them but we had
the editor Dana alvarella James
um she's trying to put together a whole
compilation kind of of that to show
people where it came from like those 13
magazines we put together like some of
the best articles and you know amazing
World's Gonna Be Together gives people
inside because that's the foundation of
my career for sure independent magazine
I did call ego trip which again I got
the book of rap list at my crib right
now on my show
um you kind of taking the source off the
top of the mountain during that double
XL not to do kinda in modesty we do
these modifiers you like bootle Kev you
like controversial statements say I did
yeah yeah and you and you and then he
might be one of the greatest well if I'm
not who is uh you understand one of the
greatest well you had them they'll say
come on stop talking with modifiers we
all do you have them selling Eminem CDs
to try to
like that was a pretty intense era of
like hip-hop journalism right but what
was what was that I like going up
against them and then I think um on my
set I have the 50 Dre Eminem cover
framed because that is to me like well
that was the same week the same month
they had job we want to cover and
there's a poster inside of a guy
breaking me in half and then cutting
Eminem's head off so I mean it was crazy
man it was like you know and then you
had Hip Hop Police also following all of
us too so that's what made it exciting
hip-hop police were following you guys
yeah like you they would pull these
dossiers and everybody related to the
culture was in the files and they you
know they tried to press me about and
actually I didn't know anything to not
tell them about anybody's dinged so I
didn't have to snitch because I actually
didn't know anything but you know they
watched all of us like if we were
affiliated with these artists at the
time and the controversy I had to foul
50 had a foul business you know how to
file everybody had a file so it was like
you also had to realize that that was
one time I would say my block was the
most hectic block because
uh they built 40 40 club was connected
to the XXL building when they built it
when they built that [__] I was like oh
my God that's insane
that I was so mad I left half day I was
pissed I was like
same block so violated henchman 40 40
club and double XL same block
crazy I feel like we've had not the best
year so far in terms of yeah we're not
number one yet right and I also just
feel like in general like there hasn't
been
hip-hop's ass too like you're that type
of person I [__] my favorite album of
the year is Killer Mike and I love the
estate sales [__] those are the two for
me yeah yeah yeah those are good but it
has been a really light year
um what's your album of the year in the
middle of 2023. I wouldn't say I'm a
year but I like those two years I also
like Gunner's album I also like uh do
you like the gun album I like the gun
album okay I like the currency Jay
Jermaine Dupree project the EP uh the uh
Larry June Alchemist album Alchemist is
good I got a good solid like top five to
seven that I like um I'm not picking
another one yet but I do think some big
dogs will come in obviously Drake's
coming as you see now with his little
book poetry scavengers
he hasn't officially announced it but it
seems like I was gonna say like every
year bdot drops his list and then I
usually drop a list right after to like
you know be like you gotta do that
support but um I know like you guys
all right when you guys drop a Rap Radar
interview or a podcast it's always an
interview yeah I feel like once a year
you you should be on his ass for like an
hour going over that list there's more
money than you get man tell them we can
generate more bags man we gotta you know
to create we could do something like
when I see top five dead or alive show
everything you know what I'm saying
Jada's coming he's not dead he's on next
oh okay okay well let's Elliot kisses
can we please do the laundry go kisses
here we gotta can we do the long form we
gotta do the long form Brothers guys
yeah hey man I appreciate your time
brother yeah